president Trump unleashed on Nancy
Pelosi over the stalled impeachment
process sending out a flurry of tweets
calling the Speaker and House Democrats
hypocrites and Liars the tweets just
part of President Ron's attacks against
the speaker my poll numbers are the
highest they've ever been our
fundraising and the Republican Party is
the highest at 17 she hates the
Republican Party she hates all of the
people that voted for me and the
Republican Party and she's desperate to
do look she got thrown out of speaker
once before she lost like 63 seats 61 or
63 tremendous a record-setting number of
seats I think it's gonna happen again
Pelosi facing growing scrutiny over her
strategy to withhold sending the
articles of impeachment to the Senate
Karl Rove saying the speaker is quote
venturing into treacherous
constitutional territory I asked him
about that earlier Nancy Pelosi wants to
usurp the constitutional role of the
Senate she has tried to as the Speaker
of the House intrude into the process
that under the Constitution is solely
set aside for the United States Senate
namely to try the impeachment of the
president the longer this goes on the
more petty the more partisan and the
more political this all looks and the
less people are gonna have confidence in
what the house did meanwhile GOP senator
Lisa Murkowski getting a lot of
attention from the media
it comes after saying she is quote
disturbed by Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell's plan to coordinate
with Trump on impeachment take a look
the first possible crack in Republican
ranks over the Senate impeachment trial
of President Trump Senator Murkowski
remarks are the first sign so far of any
dissent within the GOP a high-profile
Republican is not in line with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell she is
distinguishing herself from her
colleagues she's critical of Senate
Majority Mitch McConnell a pinpointing
his past comments just the fact that
she's saying she wants to be impartial
and is concerned about Mitch McConnell's
comments is sending shockwaves through
the Republican establishment holding on
and Murkowski like a life raft out there
Jesse yeah I don't think she's gonna do
anything damaging to the Republican
Party she's an independent minded person
she has to throw the media a bone to
make herself look like she's can
sitter it and independent but at the end
of the day she's gonna vote to acquit if
anything it's gonna be Joe Manchin maybe
even Kyrsten Sinema and Jones and
Alabama so at this end of this process
you could have the only bipartisan votes
against impeachment in the House and the
Senate
I think right now Pelosi as you said the
other day she wants the impeachment
without the acquittal but she's not
gonna get what she wants because
eventually this strategy is gonna run
out of Road the only thing she's
enjoying right now is watching Trump
complain if I were the president I would
stop
I would declare victory I would say
Nancy looks weak she looks scared and
tired and eventually the articles are
get kicked up and he'll get the
acquittal he's looking for I do like how
he's attacking her as from a dirty
district I think it's effective because
everybody can see the dirt in that
district in San Francisco and it just
reinforces the image of her as a
hypocritical politician that cares more
about the party than the people of the
country what about Senator Schumer does
you know in the media there and that
montage Michael was talking about
Murkowski and and maybe she'll flip do
they really think that Senator Schumer
is impartial no they know it and this is
all about the narrative that's all this
is
Pelosi Nancy Pelosi she knows that this
has no chance she's just being a Grinch
in trying to ruin another Prince
Christmas she knows that there's no way
Trump's gonna get in peace she just
wants to make sure everyone in America
was possibly arguing over Christmas
dinner
if anyone chokes talk to Nancy Pelosi if
your uncle bill choked on a Brussels
sprout call her call what do you think
her plan is Capri
well I Jesse alluded to this before I
mean I've said this I mean I think that
what she wants is you know to appease in
a swage her base by getting out articles
of impeachment out of the house showing
that she did after something but then
she doesn't want to run the risk of the
acquittal in the Senate because then
Trump can sit there and say look you
know I was vindicated this was all
political etc etc there's no way to
avoid it you need you know what is it
3/5 to be able to of the Senate
to be able to actually get a conviction
on impeachment that's not gonna happen
and I think that a lot of is being made
about Lisa Murkowski and some of these
other susan collins Mitt Romney I mean
these are individuals that have
consistently been critics on the
Republican side in the Senate of a whole
host of things including on the Kavanagh
issue now Murkowski did vote against
Kavanagh but people like Susan Collins
voted for so I think you know just
because they're you know in a bit of a
kerfuffle right now doesn't mean
anything at the end of that a couple of
them have races of their own that they
have to deal like Susan say so they want
where they want right in oh gosh you
made a good point and I had a thought in
my head for Nicole and now I can't
remember it
so let me give you the floor Nicole for
whatever you want to say and I think a
great question was I'm sure it was
wonderful Dana
so what Capri was essentially saying one
I don't necessarily think Nancy Pelosi
has a base that she's appealing to I
think she was against impeachment in the
beginning and now she's just trying to
appease her far-left freshmen Democrats
and I personally don't think she wanted
to do this she had to do it for
political reasons she's there even if
Murkowski Collins in Romney you know
they're not going to vote for
impeachment they're not going to get the
two-thirds vote in the Senate it's not
gonna happen and Murkowski yes she may
be critical of what McConnell is doing
but she votes 74% in line with Trump yes
yes she said that she doesn't like what
he's doing it doesn't mean that's how
she's gonna vote they're just the
media's running with this and they're
trying to open make some rumbling in
people having faith in the Republicans
is crazy
imagine the montage that we'll do when
she if she doesn't vote to impeach how
disappointed those people will be one
thing about this Jessi just from a
strategic standpoint is impeachment
doesn't pull well for Nancy Pelosi but
things like health care shoring up
social security and those types of
things do but she can't figure if they
if they're gonna be an impeachment for
the first quarter and they also have
democratic primaries there's no way that
they can get back on to those other
topics yeah I think she has to get this
done soon rather than later you have the
State of the Union coming up you have
primaries you maybe want to tack on one
more big win for her Congress
domestically before they run for
re-election in November
and then strategically going back to her
gamesmanship with Mitch I think she's
also trying to delay to just reinforce
the idea that this is a rigged Senate
trial the longer and longer her and her
media partners hammer Mitch and his
Senate could Patriots as biased and
rigged and not doing this in a way that
is fair I think she just squeezes as
much juice out of that as she can before
she eventually sends the week articles
up I truly think the biggest political
threat for these incumbent Republicans
specifically those that are more
moderates Mackowski is not necessarily
the Democrats I think in their own
primary races so they have to fall in
line with what Republicans are wanting
and polling shows that they're not for
impeachment so they can't vote for
impeachment so they'll lose in the
private the only place where these
handful of Republicans are relevant in
this context is getting more witnesses
and approving more witnesses because I
guess they only you only need a simple
majority
so say you know Murkowski and collins
and romney actually does that have any
impact on the bigger picture if they say
yes we want XYZ witnesses well actually
that was the that was the question I was
going to put so we'll give it to you as
a last question so this idea that if you
just put it out there and you polled say
do you think that there should be an
investigation
most people's like sure do you think
that it would be good to hear from more
people and more witnesses most people
yeah sure without understanding all the
other twists and turns of this maybe she
is resting on this idea that there will
be enough Republicans the same yeah look
let's let's have some more witnesses up
here well vanie bolton will get them up
here and have a conversation i think
america is split a lot of americans I
think just want to get it done with just
get it off the table it's a joke there's
no Republicans on board now it literally
is just a bad joke on Americans and then
there's people like me who I want all
the witnesses I want to call Joey Biden
I want honor Biden to testify I want to
fly over half of Ukraine together to
testify
I want Hillary if we're gonna do a show
let's do it
[Applause]
absolutely they'll be musical numbers
and maybe let's talk about this in Vegas
have your big show
absolutely what at the MGM casino go to
that if I were in New Vegas that week I
would definitely do that